Valley no more than you it's budget time
now bro have no choice
brothers and sisters don't worry it's
just food coloring but if he woke me up
for one Salah he will get the reward for
my entire Salah too but we can't wake up
people for Fajr every day around the
world but what you can do is help us
teach thousands of reverts and thousands
of Muslims who never learn how to pray
but if you're the one who gave the
hard-earned money to just sponsor one
salamat then every time that person
performs Salah you will share in the
rewards just a hundred pounds can teach
up to 10 people how to pray Salah that's
50 Watts a day eighteen thousand a year
almost a million in 50 years for just
plant the seed today by clicking the
button or the link and donating now
[Music]